Now back for the fifth week is our
ex-frontier lawmen and nephew of Wyatt Earp
from Sacramento, California whose
category is the Wild West, Virgil Earp
All your friends are out there. Do you
feel all right? New suit that's very pretty
Dandy. Isn't it dandy. Virg you come from a family
of law enforcement officers you're the nephew of
the most famous of the united states marshals
you were marshal yourself so you should know
was it was it tougher or easier to enforce law in
your days? much tougher. well because there was
some there was more crime? no there was
lesser crime. the peoples were more honest
you could leave a hulk gold in your home and
leave the door wide open it was as safe as in the
bank vault. Well then why was the job tougher?
Well because you were the arresting officer,
you took every responsibility on yourself,
you're arresting officer, the detective,
squad car, jailer and the whole thing wrapped up
in one. all one job. If it's not too personal i
don't think this will hurt you now how much did
you get paid in those days for all those duties?
$75 dollars a month and very happy all of it.
$75 dollars a month. how much did did Wyatt make?
Well, the most Wyatt made as a marshal was
when he was over all the rest in Dodge city. He
got $250 a month. $250 a month for being a
marshall that was a pretty rugged job well
couldn't you have made more
money in other ventures?
with some more fortunes. but the officer law man,
you can't make anything else out on him, and there
wouldn't be otherwise if they could. well i'm very
thankful the Earps and other men of your breed
were the law man because if it weren't for fellows
like you we're liable to have a horseman riding
up right now and hold up the whole studio. well
Virgil i'm as i say it's a fascinating history
you've had and i'm very thrilled to know you and
learn more about it from week to week. well now
let's get down to the game itself last week Virgil
you won sixteen thousand dollars you've had a week
to think it over and you're here tonight to tell
us whether you're gonna take the 16 thousand or
gamble it and go for thirty two. thirty two and
up. you're going for thirty two thousand dollars.
all right let's get going how would
you escort virgil into the booth
please
you hear me all right yeah you're all comfortable
ready for the question? ready for the
question. okay they have it please ben
the categories you know is the wild
west the question is worth $32,000 and
for that amount virgil i want you to answer the
following questions about the colorful west first
here is a map from rand mcnally's history of
our united states would you hand that map in
for mr earp please ben there's
the map now that map that you
have before you virgil shows one of
the most famous trails of the west
what is its name and what was its purpose and
in what town did it first end and why? then
wait a second virgil we'll come back to that i
want to give you the rest of this question now
second part of the question buffalo bill cody
was one of the most famous of the scouts and
indian fighters before he became a showman against
what two indian tribes did he scout for the army
from 1868 to 1872? at the battle of indian creek
he killed an indian chief in hand-to-hand combat.
what was the chief's name and what award did cody
receive from the united states government for his
services? next part of the question virgil one of
the most notorious outlaws of the west was jesse
james a song became popular immediately after
his death that went like this listen to this song
for his life three children they
were brave but that dirty little
town that shot down mr tower has laid
poor jazz in the grave did you hear that
all right virgil i want to ask you a
couple of questions about that song now
who was the mr howard mentioned in the
song and who was the man referred to
as the dirty little coward and what
was his connection with jesse james
now for the final part of this question listen
very carefully in order to identify their cattle
the western ranchers created thousands of personal
distinctive brands now look at the brands we have
illustrated may i have those please then we should
pass those into virgil forget the map for a moment
now look at those brands virgil first examine
brand number one up in that left hand corner
why was this particular brand chosen for the
ranch that used it now examine brand number two
their number two is the first
brand used in america by whom
brand number two is on the bottom there now
examine brand number three which has a very
interesting story behind it what caused this brand
to be chosen that's the question virgil you have
a little time to take over your answer good luck
well where do we stop here right after the music
right virgin we'll start with
the question concerning the map
now what is the name of the famous trail
that's chisholm trail that is correct
what purpose did it serve it served to run the
longhorns to the shipping market on the railroad
from the long orange from where or from
the panhandle of texas that is correct in
what town did it originally end why it ended in
abilene on the accident fragrant that is correct
why did it end there well the railroad
hadn't moved up yet that was the first
that was really the end of the railroad when
they shipped from abilene that is correct
now you can put both those things down now
virgil we'll get to the brands a little later
so hold them hold them with you now the second
part of the question concerned buffalo bill cody
buffalo bill cody served as scout for the army
against two indian tribes which two tribes
the soos and the shanghams that is correct
what indian sheath did he defeat
in combat uh yellow what was that
that is correct what high decoration did he
receive he received the congressional medal of
honor that is correct now concerning the song
that you heard who in the song was mr howard
for jesse james that is correct who was
referred to as the dirty little coward
bob ford bob ford is correct and what was his
connection with jesse james well he was one of the
gang of outlaws under jesse and frank james that
is correct he was a member of his gang now you
can get a picture of the brands in front of you
concerning the brands virgil brand number one
why was it chosen by the ranch that used it well
as a ranch in texas with covers approximately six
counties or ten counties the x was a numeral
number for the ten and the i was for uh
virtual to be fair in texas tandem texas illinois
that is in texas okay that is right now brand two
this is the first brand used in america
yeah by whom was it used for cortez
fernando cortez is correct to capture
mexico one more brand to identify for
thirty two thousand dollars what unusual
reason caused the choice of this brand
well they were having a big poker game and the
rancher that owned this particular ranch had went
broke as far as money so he staked his ranch
against the money on one bed and his opposer
had four sixes and went in the ranch
yep so he thought nothing better for
branding iron than four sixes the man who
won the ranch wanted the poker hand with
four sixes four sixes and that became
its brand yes you're right for 32 000.
and marshall congratulations again you've
just won 32 big ones your next question is
worth 64 000 and if you can dig up and i mean
literally dig up a better expert than you are
you can bring him to the studio and help
you if you decide to go for 64 000. i seen
an ex-arizonan ex-senator yesterday in the
office yeah wonderful well i'm sure he was
glad to see you virgil thanks for being with
us tonight we'll see you next week good night